bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct toute la semaine vous le savez
les présidents de groupe se succèdent
dans cette émission pour dresser le
bilan des un an de la nouvelle Assemblée
vous le voyez ce soir c'est une
présidence bonsoir Mathilde de panneau
pas trop des insoumis merci d'être là
les insoumis à vous qui n'ont sans doute
peut-être jamais aussi bien porter leur
nom que depuis cette année d'élections
première année de nouvelle Assemblée on
va en parler sur le fond sur la forme et
puis on va parler de la muppesse aussi
un nom déjà initiative largement voilà
des insoumis mais pas seulement on verra
si elle a encore un avenir on en parle
tout à l'heure mais on commence ce soir
avec trois lettres trois lettres qui
donnent des sueurs froides aux élus
locaux zanes pour 0 artificialisation
nette c'est l'objectif de la loi climat
voté il y a deux ans seulement voilà
deux ans après sur le terrain et bien la
lutte contre le tour béton devient une
sorte de Mission Impossible en pleine
crise du logement alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait des exceptions des exemptions les
députés notamment les sénateur s aussi
sont par du sujet on en débat dans un
instant sur ce plateau avec mes invités
avant de retrouver nos parties pris nos
affranchis et puis dans Bourbon spécial
ce soir Bourbon Express un an et bien on
va parler du name and shame consacrée à
l'Assemblée voilà pour le programme vous
suivez mettez le panneau ça vous regarde
c'est parti
[Musique]
où placer le curseur entre les terres
agricoles et les terrains constructibles
à l'heure de l'urgence climatique la loi
climat fruit de la convention citoyenne
votée en 2021 est devenu la cible de
beaucoup beaucoup d'élus locaux alors
levée de bouclier pour dénoncer une
sorte d'usine à gaz sur le terrain qui a
trouvé un certain écho au Sénat en
pleine campagne des sénatoriales à leur
faut-il revoir attention c'est pas
facile l'objectif du Zam le zéro
artificialisation nette prévue dans
cette loi climat bonsoir Bastien
Marchive merci d'être là vous êtes
député à part enterré renaissance des
Deux-Sèvres et vous êtes le rapporteur à
l'assemblée de cette proposition de loi
qui arrive du Sénat elle est examinée en
commission elle arrive dans l'hémicycle
la semaine prochaine vous allez dire ce
que vous allez en faire de ce texte
c'est pas votre groupe politique est-ce
que vous allez le rejeter ou peut-être
même le réécrire bonsoir Aminata Niakate
merci d'être là vous êtes porte-parole
d'Europe Écologie les verbes bonsoir
chef tel ravi de vous retrouver
journaliste à Libération chargée de la
ville de urbanisme et du Logement enfin
bonsoir Jean-Philippe dugouin Clément on
a forcément besoin d'un maire sur ce
plateau ça tombe bien vous êtes le maire
de Mennecy dans l'Essonne mère centre
droit je crois que vous êtes au prix
avec cette question des d'usanes auteur
de l'habitat Fels citoyen aux Éditions
de l'Aube Mathilde panot on voit que ce
sujet est remonte partout du terrain
peut-être même dans le Val-de-Marne
votre circonscription donc évidemment
n'hésitez pas à participer à intervenir
même à interroger nos invités on
commence par planter le décor les ânes
en 200 secondes c'est un défi le chrono
de Blacko tout de suite
bonsoir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir Myriam
bonsoir à toutes et tous alors le tout
béton avant de parler on va peut-être
essayer d'expliquer de quoi on parle
donc on va partir d'un chiffre choc qui
a été révélé par Cour des comptes qui
disait en 2020 que entre 2010 et 2020
600 000 hectares de terre donc naturelle
ont été bétonnés en France qui est
correspond à l'équivalent d'un
département donc à ce rythme là au bout
d'un siècle on a bétonné l'ensemble de
la France alors le coupable en plus
c'est désigné par la Cour des comptes
c'est marqué ici la raison c'est
l'étalement
urbain ce fameux rêve français du
papillon avec jardin pourquoi pas une
piscine pendant qu'on y est et ça
évidemment c'est un résultat c'est que
la ville grignote sur la campagne ce qui
est une catastrophe écologique c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est lui
on a construit un modèle de société où
la promotion sociale le progrès la
réussite passée par avoir son pavillon à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres du
centre-ville conduire les enfants à des
activités dès qu'ils sont pas à l'école
et donc un modèle on a le pavillon on a
de l'étalement urbain où on a deux
véhicules par foyer etc etc et à cet
égard en effet faut réussir à revenir
sur cette
cette catastrophe française qui a été
l'artificialisation des sols alors ça
c'était en 2020 et le président voulait
être remarqué s'exprimait devant la
compétition citoyenne pour le climat
donc dès l'année suivante ça s'est
traduit dans une loi qui était adoptée à
l'Assemblée qui a été un grand principe
celui du van donc
diminué de moitié l'artificialisation
des sols ici 2030 et pour arriver à 2050
à 0 artificialisation supplémentaire
donc sur le principe tout le monde était
plus ou moins d'accord au départ c'est à
dire que pour les agriculteurs ça leur
donner le sentiment qu'on protégerait
leurs terres agricoles pour les
écologiste que ça éviterait le bétonnage
de la nature et même pour le
gouvernement ça sans doute ainsi très à
revitaliser les centres-villes des
petites villes de province qui est un de
ces objectifs sauf que en 2022 quand il
a fallu traduire ça le grand principe
dans des décrets et voilà ça commence à
coincer parce que les maires avaient
quand même l'impression que ce truc
d'usage ça allait les priver de l'un de
leurs pouvoirs principaux qui est
pouvoir décider du plan d'occupation de
la commune donc de délivrer des permis
de construire ce qui n'est d'ailleurs
pas totalement pour résultat la MF qui
est donc l'Association des maires de
France c'est révélé ces îles conseils
d'État pour contester ces
pardon et puis vous savez que dans ce
qu'on s'en prend au maire collectivités
locales le Sénat ne tarde jamais trop à
monter alors ce cours et donc ils ont ça
c'était en mars déposer une proposition
de loi pour adoucir arrondir un peu les
conditions d'application d'usage qu'on
peut donner un exemple par exemple si
l'État décide d'installer un grand
projet sur votre commune sans que vous
l'ayez décidé faudrait pas que ça vous
grille votre crédit terrain donc les
meilleurs pas mal le droit de garder
leur crédit pour faire des projets
personnels tu sais qu'il y a 36 000
communes en France donc 36000 cas
différents donc on a aussi prévu pour
les petites communes des exceptions pour
pas qu'elles subissent les fins que
j'écoute les mêmes règles que Paris bref
vu que le gouvernement n'a pas
l'intention de s'attacher ni avec le
Sénat ni avec les collectivités locales
donc Christophe Béchu a assez vite
trouvé un compromis avec les sénateurs
pour que le texte donc soit un peu
aménagé et puis surtout voter devant
l'Assemblée où il est examiné en ce
moment on croyait être sorti du tunnel
mais voilà que nouvelle distension
apparaît cette fois-ci au sein même du
gouvernement Christophe béchute bon il
est quand même ministre de l'écologie
après tout donc l'idée que les maires ne
soient pas prisonniers des projets que
l'État d'instag chez eux à la limite il
peut comprendre mais il veut pas que les
usines échappent complètement aux ânes
sauf que pendant ce temps-là il y en a
qui essaient de réindustrialiser la
France alors forcément ils sont pas
contents on les écoute
je suis favorable à ce que les projets
d'industrie vertes que ce soit les
projets d'intérêt national où les autres
projets de PME et de TI soit exclus du
calcul du zan c'est ma position je le
dis très simplement sa position de mise
de l'économie et des finances elle n'est
pas encore définitivement arbitré
ce qu'il emportera est-ce que Christophe
bechy aurait plus d'influence au
gouvernement que Bruno Demers en tout
cas Bruno Le Maire il peut compter à
priori sur le soutien de LR ou au moins
de Livia Marleix qui n'a pas l'air de
porter le vin dans son cœur en l'écoute
aujourd'hui on le voit dans nos
territoires on n'est plus capable
d'implanter des grandes entreprises
parce que on a plus de foncier on a plus
de réserve et on nous interdit dans dans
consommer mais le zéro en utilisation
c'est de l'écologie radicale et le
gouvernement et les otages de cette de
cette écologie alors je vais vous
laisser débattre bien sûr juste un petit
détail peut-être à l'attention de noter
les spectateurs en septembre ce sont les
élections sénatoriales peut-être pour ça
que tout le monde est au chevet des
campagnes vous
ez chacun bah justement merci beaucoup
Stéphane je commence avec vous sur le
contexte dans lequel justement c'est
remise en cause de ce zan arrive il y a
les campagnes des sénatoriales et puis
il y a la crise du logement voilà ça
arrive dans ce moment là très
particulier ça milite pourquoi à votre
avis pour d'urgence revoir ses
dispositifs ou se dire attention
récupération
écoutez je pense que la première des
choses déjà c'est de se dire que la
France est le plus gros consommateur
foncier d'Europe c'est 15% de plus qu'en
Allemagne et c'est 57% de plus qu'au
Royaume-Uni qui a pourtant une
population qui est semblable ce qui veut
dire que sur les 50 dernières années on
a beaucoup artificialisé de par le
modèle qui a pu être évoqué mais je ne
connais pas bien le sujet donc je vous
interrompre mais on fait de la pédagogie
9%
en France de zones artificielles
sur l'ensemble du territoire moi je vois
ce chiffre je me dis bah c'est pas
beaucoup je me trompe il faut se
rappeler pourquoi est-ce qu'on a adopté
la loi climat derrière ça c'est des
enjeux de préservation de la
biodiversité de préservation également
du stockage du CO2 il y a également des
enjeux de cycle de l'eau qui sont à
prendre en compte c'est à dire que un
seul une fois qu'il est artificialisé il
ne remplit plus sa fonction première sur
le plan environnemental et une capte la
loi de climat c'est exactement ça et la
loi climat elle a justement cette
ambition de faire en sorte qu'on ne
tombe pas dans des excès qui aurait un
impact significatif en matière de
réchauffement climatique alors après on
peut la caricaturer moi je pense qu'il
ne faut pas opposer
sobriété foncière et construction on
peut continuer à construire il faut
simplement repenser nos modes de
construction et c'est tout l'enjeu de la
loi climat et du texte qu'on a également
la question c'est est-ce que les
temporalités sont compatibles il y a
besoin de logements tout de suite alors
Aminata
pardonnez-moi d'abord je voudrais
comprendre on dit 9% d'artificialisation
a priori c'est peu mais le problème
français c'est l'étalement
urbain c'est ça qui est le plus mauvais
pour l'environnement ces fameux
pavillons cette France périphérique avec
des zones industrielles des zones
commerciales qui fait que finalement
même si c'est 9 % si c'est disséminé par
tout ça donne pas de bonne terre ben
c'est certain que l'étalement urbain est
un problème pour la pleine terre qui
remplit un certain nombre de services
écologiques et pour une fois je suis
d'accord avec ce que vous dites il y a
des enjeux sur l'eau il y a des anges
sur le sur le climat et on doit lutter
contre le plus grand enjeu du siècle et
et évidemment il faut revenir sur enfin
il faut il faut garder cette loi c'était
une bonne idée la loi de climat le
problème c'est c'est le manque de
pilotage de les collectivités sont
livrées à elles-mêmes c'est pas pensé à
la à la bonne échelle et moi je crois
fondamental donc c'est mal fait la loi
est mal faite vous êtes écologiste vous
activités sont livrées à elles-mêmes etc
et puis en plus les mères sont assez
dépendantes du foncier en termes de
revenus la taxe d'habitation a disparu
elle dépend de la taxe foncière elle
dépendent aussi de la de la CFE de la
contribution française c'est que on n'a
pas évidemment en fonction des villes la
même densité en fonction des zones
rurales en fonction et pourtant
l'objectif est le même pour tous c'est
ça monsieur le Maire comment on explique
au fond cette règle un petit peu je veux
dire voilà
égalitariste en fait c'est tous les
impensés de la loi la trajectoire zan
c'est en fait c'est quoi c'est la
réduction de l'extension
urbaine c'est protéger l'éternel tout le
monde la partage je pense qu'auteur de
ce plateau personne ne dira qu'il ne
faut pas artificialiser moins de terre
le problème qui se pose c'est le
financement l'usage aujourd'hui qui pose
un vrai sujet sur le logement et c'est
le détail d'un texte qui a été mal fichu
la loi d'août 2021 et encore plus c'est
décret d'application ou un certain
nombre qui sur le terrain très
concrètement bloque tout quand on compte
par exemple le jardin d'un pavillon
comme étant artificialisé ça veut dire
que dans des villages on les vitrifie on
va perdre de la population et on va
fermer des écoles on a toute une série
en fait de type de règlement qui ne vont
pas n'ont pas sur l'objectif chercher
mais vraiment sur la méthode dans les
choses qui peuvent effectivement choquer
si on met tout le monde à la même à la
même enseigne que vous ayez été très
vertueux depuis des années que vous ayez
réduit très fortement votre
artificialisation depuis des années ou
qu'au contraire vous ayez tartiné de
l'étalement urbain on vous impose la
même règle on divise par deux élèves
sont pénalisés ils se retrouvent
totalement pénalisés on tient pas compte
de la densité de population du potentiel
de développement économique si on prend
Paris c'est la septième capitale la plus
dense au monde l'Ile-de-France pour le
secteur intram et trop politain les
départements de petites couronnes c'est
la métropole la plus dense en Europe et
ont alors qu'à l'inverse on a des
secteurs très durs très ruraux et donc
en fait on la même règle à tout le monde
c'est toute la question en fait qui doit
être tranchée aujourd'hui par les
modifications de loi et de décret c'est
de remettre un peu de méthode dans un
principe que tout le monde partage on
verra comment dans un instant parce
qu'il faut qu'on comprenne comment ça se
passe sur le terrain va-t-il panneau on
a une écologie qui nous dit la loi est
bonne dans son objectif mais pas
forcément dans les moyens pour déjà pour
qu'on comprenne tous là je veux citer un
rapport qui a été rendu par la fabrique
écologique qui montre que
l'artificialisation des sols qui a été
fait a été fait à 70% sur des terres qui
étaient agricoles et qui étaient bonnes
pour la souveraineté alimentaire de la
France donc ça par exemple c'est un
objectif d'arrêter complètement ça
d'artificialiser sur des terres
agricoles je pense que c'est très
important on a perdu 2,4 millions
d'hectares agricoles depuis 1982 donc
c'est un objectif fort la souveraineté
alimentaire sur la question du cycle de
l'eau et notamment les inondations qu'on
voit très fréquemment et de plus en plus
fréquemment sur notre territoire sont
liés un problème d'infiltration des eaux
je crois que sur les objectifs tout le
monde mais je les redis quand même c'est
dans le premier responsable parce que
c'est quand même important pour que tout
le monde comprenne pourquoi est-ce que
cet objet il est important et il est
important à tenir sur la mise en œuvre
après sur la mise en œuvre là où je
partage des choses je trouve que c'est
intéressant par exemple les mers ruraux
qui ont dit nous avons besoin d'un plan
Marshall sur la rénovation du bâti qui
est aujourd'hui vacant vous savez qu'on
a 3,2 millions de logements qui sont
vacants dans notre pays et lorsque vous
avez par exemple des maires de communes
rurales qui disent par exemple j'ai 5
maisons qui sont en ruines dans mon
village et je n'ai pas les moyens de
pouvoir les rénover et donc il faut un
plan Marshall un plan de financement
pour aider un plan aussi d'ingénierie de
l'État pour aider à ce qu'on rénove et
qu'on fasse en sorte de ne pas
artificialiser des nouvelles car je vois
que ces deux coups la question des
moyens financiers sur les questions
systémiques qui ne sont pas pensées sur
la question du rapprocher les lieux de
travail et les lieux de vie ainsi que
les services publics ça c'est une chose
qui en terme justement de ne pas refaire
des routes de partout des autoroutes qui
là aussi artificialisent souvent des
terres agricoles est une chose
importante qui est là aussi un impensé
et qui nécessite
un reportage en Bretagne on reviendra
sur le concret avec le maire mais pour
terminer le tour de table fftel d'abord
cette grogne qui montre vous vous avez
enquêté vous les avez rencontré les
maires elle est elle dépasse l'écrivage
politique elle concerne qui en
particulier plutôt les petites communes
rurales au détriment des grosses villes
moi j'ai rencontré aussi beaucoup de
mères qui sont très favorables à
l'objectif et qui ne le met en oeuvre
déjà depuis des années il faut voir que
certes on a beaucoup artificialisé tout
à fait depuis les années 70 un qui
correspond à un modèle d'urbanisation on
le sait avec les centres commerciaux à
l'extérieur le pavillon etc financé par
des dispositifs publics d'accession à la
propriété mais ça a diminué quand même
depuis une dizaine d'années il y a eu de
nouveau sermenté un peu après le covid
pas envie d'aller tout gelé mais quand
même il faut reprendre quand même un
chiffre vous avez dit 9% de surface
artificialisée moi j'ai regardé la
dernière enquête qui fait foi qui
l'enquête est Ruthie c'est 7,9%
exactement donc c'est moins de 8% de la
France qui est urbanisée sachant que la
France est quand même un des pays
peut-être qui a le plus en rythme
artificialisé mais qui est aussi un des
plus grands pays d'Europe et le moins
dense donc voilà et la remet en cause
l'objectif
enfin moi je les formidable cet objectif
c'est important d'en avoir un mais mais
ça reste un objectif après oui
effectivement les moyens comment on y
arrive etc et sur la fronde parce qu'on
l'entend cette levée de bouclier c'est
plus la droite on sait que l'AMF
l'Association des maires de France a
fait un cheval de bataille ou c'est
vraiment toute une question pragmatique
concrète notamment dans la ruralité
c'est mal fait ça c'est mal pensé et
c'est mal financé
je saurais pas dire si c'est oui
effectivement la MF David Lisnard était
très ouais en pointe sur le sujet
mais non enfin moi j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de mères pour qui qui sont en
train de réfléchir qui déjà
réfléchissaient comment on fait
concrètement effectivement il y a l'idée
qu'on va recycler spontanément on va
davantage recycler les friches pour
éviter de d'artificialiser et ça c'est
aussi encouragé par le gouvernement il y
a des fonds pour ça il y a le fond
friche etc donc il y a quand même des
financements qui existent et qui le
pratique déjà vraiment donc on réfléchit
à chaque fois évitons évitons le c'est
moins l'étalement que le mitage évitons
le c'est quoi la différence
pardonnez-moi mais mitage est tellement
le pavillon seul qui va être loin et qui
va du coup obligé à tirer des réseaux
faire une route etc donc ça c'est cette
émiettement disons et néfaste après
l'étalement c'est devenu un peu un mot
voilà épouvantail mais
les Français aussi ont besoin de se
loger et si possible en priorité dans
les logements neufs qui existent dans
les 3 millions de logements pardon les
logements je voulais dire vacants
notamment de centre bourg il y a 3
millions de logements en vacances donc
ça c'est vrai que ça devrait être la
priorité le gouvernement devient fléchir
bien de fléchir le péter des aides dans
cette direction d'ailleurs ouh là là pas
trop de cycle s'il vous plaît déjà avec
Lausanne c'est suffisant on part en
Bretagne et je vous redonne la parole
juste après en quoi ce cet objectif du
zan et bien oblige les élus concrètement
sur le terrain et pourquoi ça coince
caméra embarquée avec Michael pierre
Michael Carniel André Lafont à locmallow
c'est un petit village dans le Finistère
regardez
voici une espèce en voie de disparition
le pavillon si cher aux Français avec la
loi climat il ne pourra bientôt plus
rogner sur les terres agricoles le maire
de Locmalo a conscience qu'il devra
changer ses habitudes en ce qui concerne
la délivrance du permis de construire et
l'aménagement de son territoire il va
falloir comme travailler différemment
densifier
tels
les espaces verts un peu plus restreint
mais peut-être mieux travailler voilà
des choses comme ça et puis ben sur des
zones plus
urbaines de faire en effet du
bâti à deux à plusieurs niveaux avec des
fonctionnements peut-être de la personne
âgée en rez-de-chaussée un changement dû
aux femmes ânes car comme les autres
communes locmallow devra diviser par
deux la surface des nouveaux terrains à
construire d'ici 2031 aucune nouvelle
terre ne pourra devenir constructible à
partir de 2050 un casse-tête pour le
maire du village de 900 habitants avec
peu de moyens
ce qui peut être angoissant c'est le
manque d'ingénierie et le manque de
financement pour renaturer par exemple
un vieux parking y faire du logement où
y faire un parc où il fait voilà pour en
compensation il va falloir de l'argent
qu'on a pas forcément pas nous en tout
cas les petites communes et également le
manque d'ingénierie sur des petites
communes où il y a une personne en
secrétaire de mairie et peut-être deux
et pour le coup c'est hyper compliqué en
milieu rural c'est ce qui nous manque le
plus pourtant le maire a déjà pris les
devants et entame la transition
écologique de Locmalo
salut Richard la commune a racheté de
vieilles longères elles sont
réhabilitées avec l'aide d'un architecte
ouais
merci d'être venu il y a pas de souci en
plus de valoriser le patrimoine
l'objectif est de rationaliser l'espace
en favorisant les logements à étages
aujourd'hui on va faire une médiathèque
on va faire trois logements communaux
pour des personnes ayant peu de moyens
réhabiliter coûte plus cher que de
construire du neuf mais pour
l'architecte le projet revitalisent le
cœur de la commune c'est pas moins cher
mais par contre on valorise un bien
c'est tout un cadre en fait qui est
valorisé c'est-à-dire que là où on va
peut-être faire du neuf des pavillons
neufs admettons dans un bourg qu'est-ce
qu'on construit dans le bourg on
construit simplement un dortoir on
construit un lieu de vie une activité au
cœur de Bourg
locmallow ne compte pas s'arrêter là la
commune va racheter réhabilité d'autres
vieilles bâtisses pour continuer de se
développer sans toucher roter agricoles
alors Jean-Philippe Dugoin Clément vous
vous reconnaissez j'imagine dans les
difficultés de ce maire même si sa ville
est plus petite que la vôtre mais que ça
soit moi ou des collègues en fait déjà
ce qu'il faut bien avoir conscience
c'est contrairement à ce qui est dit la
division par deux c'est pas pour chaque
commune c'est pour chaque région alors
qu'il y a des communes qui ont 0 qui ne
peuvent plus rien faire il faut
expliquer ça parce que l'objectif est
national mais il est aussi local c'est à
dire qu'il est décliné dans les
départements dans les régions et chaque
région doit diviser par deux sa
consommation foncière par rapport à la
dernière décennie et donc selon la
répartition qui est faite il peut très
bien rester zéro pour une commune
c'est-à-dire qu'une commune ou un
village peut se retrouver à ne pas avoir
une division par deux mais à ne plus
avoir un mètre carré d'extension si on
prend l'exemple des grands projets qui
étaient évoqué tout à l'heure le canal
senor pour les hauts de France c'est
quelque chose qui si ça n'est pas sorti
des comptabilisations de la région prend
quasiment toutes les possibilités
d'extension de la région et en fait le
débat technique
il est là-dessus il est pas sur le fait
de dire on fait des efforts on consomme
moins il est vraiment sur les
déclinaisons techniques il y a un
contrôleur on dit que c'est le préfet
qui doit valider les plans locaux
d'urbanisme qui joue un petit peu les
les empêcheurs de tourner en rond c'est
lui le préfet qui qui essaye de vérifier
que l'objectif du zen et bien respecté
il n'est pas mis en œuvre c'est-à-dire
que la loi date de 2021 la diminution de
trajectoire il est sur 2021 2030 et
c'est aux régions chaque région doit
mettre en place Lausanne sur son
territoire et ensuite les communes
auront trois ans sur leur plu pour se
mettre en conformité c'est à dire qu'en
fait le PLU c'est quoi c'est d'urbanisme
où est-ce qu'on peut construire ou
est-ce qu'on construit pas où est-ce
qu'on fait des équipements publics ou
est-ce qu'on fait du logement quelle
densité de logement à la parcelle quelle
quantité d'espaces verts à la parcelle
et en fait la réalité c'est que les PLU
d'application d'usane ne sont pas encore
construction aujourd'hui car
construction aujourd'hui c'est les
trajectoires régionales alors je vais
vous dire des sera d'être des drift
c'est horrible c'est des actes
régionales mais elles ont une force
contraignante elles sont décidés
si je comprends bien l'idée c'est de
garder l'objectif mais de mieux le
mettre en oeuvre peut-être en en faisant
des exceptions ou en tout cas en sortant
un certain nombre de secteurs de la
comptabilité de la région déjà sur la
ruralité et sénateurs ils mettent en
avant la garantie rurale c'est quoi
c'est un hectare préservé pour ces
petites communes pour qu'elle n'ait pas
au fond les mêmes règles que les plus
grosses alors cette idée de déroger
c'est la proposition de loi du Sénat ce
n'est pas l'orientation qu'on a prise et
le texte qui a été voté en commission
pas plus tard qu'hier ne retiens pas
cette idée de déroger pourquoi on l'a
dit il y a des considérations
environnementales on les a adoptés il y
a deux ans elles sont pour 30 ans on va
pas 2 ans après d'ores et déjà commencé
à dire qu'on va pas les respecter alors
même qu'on a pas commencé à les décliner
parce que c'est compliqué l'idée c'est
d'être respecté mais sans imposer que
cette comptabilité
de baisse de trajectoire du de
l'artifice sur la commune ou sur la
région ça peut être pris ce qu'il y a un
gâteau commun et on fait une part à part
si je comprends bien il y a deux enjeux
on a 125 000 hectares de droit à
construire sur la période 2021 2031
c'est deux fois moins que sur la
décennie précédente c'est 125 000
hectares on vient en déduire une
enveloppe forfaitaire dans laquelle on a
identifié des projets d'intérêt
nationaux et d'envergure nationale ou
européenne ces projets ça va être la
transition énergétique ça va être le
développement de l'infirroviaire par
exemple ça va être aussi l'industrie
verte l'objectif c'est de pouvoir
garantir que ces projets vont bien se
réaliser et c'était l'une des attentes
je pense qui était exprimée également
par Monsieur Bruno Le Maire donc là on
répond à cette attente que vous sortez
de la comptabilisation
et ce que veut Bruno Le Maire je pense
c'est que ces projets là puissent se
faire et là on vient garantir en les
mettant dans un forfait on les déduit
des 125 000 et ensuite les 110 000 on
les répartit entre l'ensemble des
territoires et c'est ensuite décliné par
les régions et un niveau plus infra en
gros les industries vertes seront soumis
aux âmes mais sans pénaliser les
communes par exemple d'un côté en fait
pour expliquer en fait en fait il y a
une enveloppe et cette enveloppe c'est
la garantie contiennent l'objectif sinon
c'est comme d'habitude on se donne un
objectif et jamais on ne l'atteint
notamment parce que les moyens ne sont
pas donnés en ingénierie en financier en
investissement etc en gros vous avez le
ministre Béchu qui dit il faut tenir
l'enveloppe pour tenir l'objectif même
si on met pas les moyens derrière donc
il y a un petit côté hypocrite mais
voilà et vous avez Bruno Le Maire qui
dit je veux que on sorte certains des
projets de l'enveloppe donc en quelque
sorte il enveloppe plus plein d'autres
choses qui la garantie que l'enveloppe
ne s'a pas tenu et donc que les
objectifs sur l'artificialisation sur la
question de d'aggraver le restaurant
l'arbitrage des parents etc et ben c'est
ça donc c'est ça en fait le rapport de
force qui est en train de se jouer allez
claire puisque le test dont on a adopté
hier en présence du ministre et suite à
une des réunions qui ont eu lieu en
interministériel elle a été celle-ci de
dire nous avons une comptabilité
nationale du droit à construire on en
déduit un projet d'envergure national et
ensuite on répartit le droit
de gagner ou de perdre là où on gagne
c'est de garantir que ces projets là
puissent se faire puisque c'est des
projets de politique publique qui sont
structurant l'échelle du pays et on
souhaite qu'il se fasse et après pour
vous répondre sur la ruralité c'est
l'enjeu évidemment de la garantie rurale
ça a été dit tout à l'heure
le risque qu'il y avait c'est que on
avait des communes qui avaient très peu
artificialisées lors de la décennie
précédente qui mécaniquement se
retrouvait avec très peu et c'est ce
qu'on appelait les bons élèves quelque
part parce qu'il avait été sobre sur le
plafonds
territorial en terme de répartition de
ces fameux droit à construire l'objectif
de cette garantir rurale c'est de donner
un état c'est ce que proposait les
sénateurs on a eu le débat hier il aura
lieu également en hémicycle mais
finalement c'est pas tant de savoir si
c'est un état ou pas ce qui est
important c'est de savoir qui en
bénéficie et à quelles conditions
aujourd'hui l'orientation qui est prise
c'est de faire en bénéficier les
communes des olives c'est un peu
technique mais les communes dites peu
dense ou très peu dense au sens l'Insee
à savoir concrètement ça représente 31
000 communes en France qui se verront
garantir un droit à construire minimum
d'un hectare et il y a un autre élément
qui est quand même déterminant c'est que
cette logique que l'on trouve à
l'échelle nationale pour les projets
d'envergure national on souhaite pouvoir
la décliner en faisant confiance et en
laissant la liberté aux élus locaux de
pouvoir la décliner également à
l'échelle régionale et à l'échelle
intercommunale d'accord
mise en oeuvre parce que oui il y avait
un enjeu de tenir compte de la
particularité des spécificités de chaque
territoire après j'entends aussi les
enjeux de financement je pense qu'il y a
des enjeux de fiscalité sur le foncier
également qui vont se poser parce que
mécaniquement on va avoir une
raréfaction foncière et des phénomènes
de spéculation ou de rétention qu'il
nous faudra traiter je pense que le PLF
peut être un bon lieu pour en parler
mais on le voit il y a plein d'autres
considérations mais je n'ai toute petite
commune qui craignent que la tractivité
économique soit vraiment réduite à zéro
qui ont besoin de construire qui ont
besoin l'enjeu de ce texte et si je peux
juste terminer
une faille opposée le les objectifs du
zan sachant que Lausanne c'est pour 2050
on y est pas encore donc quand on parle
de crise du logement en l'occurrence il
a le dollar mais il a encore rien à voir
là-dedans je ne pense pas qu'il faille
opposer logement et zan je pense pas
qu'il faille se dire que mieux
construire ça veut dire ne plus
construire on a quand même un droit à
construire qui sera encore significatif
et quand on évoque par exemple une
moyenne de 8 logements à l'hectare c'est
la moyenne de ce qui a été construit sur
les 10 dernières années 8 logements à
l'hectare ça fait des parcelles moyennes
de plus de 1000 mètres carrés et on
tient compte des métropoles dans ce dans
ce décompte là donc on le voit quand
même qu'on a une marge diminuer de
moitié il suffirait c'est très trivial
mais il suffirait de diminuer par deux
la surface moyenne des terrains qui
accueillent des maisons individuelles
pour le régler sur la période des 10 ans
qui arrive donc pour vous on n'est pas
du tout dans l'alerte on n'est pas dans
une usine à gaz épouvantable 170
000 dollars de friche on a un vrai
mobilisé de rénovation énergétique sur
lesquelles des moyens conséquents sont
mis donc on a encore la marge de
confinement
que c'est pas lui qui porterait voilà
une fine cet arbitrage Aminata Niakate
on entend voilà l'objectif est cette
majorité il tient mais il y a des
assouplissements notamment la garantie
rurale ça va dans le bon sens pour les
écologistes moi c'est vrai que quand
j'entends parler de alors on continue la
cadence sur les grands projets les
opérations d'intérêt nationale les
grands génitaux etc type j'imagine que
l'autoroute a69 vous la mettez dedans
donc je suis assez inquiète de ce que ça
peut donner réellement enfin aujourd'hui
30% des nouvelles artificialisations de
concernent les commerces les bureaux etc
et j'ai l'impression qu'on continue on
continue comme avant et puis aussi un
autre un autre aspect c'est que sur les
nouvelles artificialisations mètres qui
arrivent les constructions et donc la
promotion immobilière ça concerne très
souvent des des zones très faibles en
tension sur le logement ou des zones en
démographie qui baisent et donc là où il
y a des besoins c'est pas là qu'on
artificialise donc un vrai problème de
pilotage et de planification bon
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
différentes on sent assouplissements à
l'oeuvre ce qui est ce qui est très bien
expliqué par Monsieur le Député
que ce soit les propositions de loi
actuelle ou les décrets c'est des choses
qui pour nous vont plutôt dans le bon
sens qu'en fait ça vient remettre un peu
de bon sens un peu d'huile dans les
rouages d'une mécanique encore une fois
que tout le monde partage après la
question du financement c'est sur les
impensés par rapport à la production de
logements et notamment de production de
logements sociaux parce que produire du
logement social quand le foncier serai
que le foncier vaut plus cher c'est
encore plus dur que de produire du
logement privé et puis globalement on
parle beaucoup des friches on pourrait
parler des zones d'activité économiques
hors qualification la transformation
bureau logement mais tout ça ça coûte
plus cher que la construction ex nihilo
et donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
travailler les régimes fiscaux ou les
simplifications qu'on peut apporter
là-dessus un mode conclusion pour avoir
suivi le dossier depuis le 24 août 2021
la le vote de la loi climat résilience
ça avance ça avance je veux dire cet
acronyme ça y est les gens le
connaissent ce sont approprié et on est
en train de changer notre manière de
penser d'urbaniser etc et ça c'est quand
même vraiment très positif au delà voilà
de la question du comment oui du comment
etc et ça va se régler en fait je pense
que c'est de la police on va trouver une
bonne manière de faire une bonne
intelligence en déclinant effectivement
les objectifs au niveau nationaux
régionaux intercommunaux et voilà
écoutez on s'arrête là
je vous remercie parce que c'était pas
simple à comprendre au départ et c'est
beaucoup plus clair ce soir merci merci
beaucoup d'être venu débattre sur LCP
vous restez avec moi Mathilde panot dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties
prises de nos affranchis ce soir le
regard du philosophe Pierre-Henri
tavoyeuse sur la polémique récente sur
les jours fériés la plume acérée de
Vincent Huger sur la visite en France de
Mohamed Ben Salman le prince héritier et
puis nouvel épisode de notre série
Bourbon Express spécial un an Marco
pommier de quoi nous parlez-vous ce soir
et ben ce soir je vais vous parler d'une
amazing une arme politique redoutable
vous verrez merci messieurs à tout à
l'heure mais d'abord on va revenir avec
vous Mathilde de panneaux sur les 1 an
des insoumis au Palais Bourbon vous
étiez 17 dans la précédente législature
vous voilà désormais 75 première force
de la nuque mais sans Jean-Luc Mélenchon
dont l'ombre il faut bien le dire plane
encore sur votre groupe alors
qu'avez-vous fait de ces un an regardez
c'est dans l'invitation Marion Becquart
on en parle ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Mathilde panot c'est
pour revenir sur l'année de la France
insoumise à l'Assemblée car vous êtes la
présidente d'un groupe d'oppositions qui
sait se faire entendre quitte parfois à
électriser les débats vous êtes un
imposteur et un assassin vous gérez 74
députés insoumis et dans l'hémicycle il
porte bien leur nom
[Musique]
vous êtes devenu les champions des
rappels au règlement et des sanctions
je vous rappelle alors
monsieur Boyard
je prononce à votre rencontre un appel à
lampe avec inscription procès-verbal
au-delà de ces coups d'éclat vous faites
entendre votre voix contre la politique
et les méthodes du gouvernement vous
êtes vous-même sans concession et
reconnu pour vos talents d'oratrice à la
tribune depuis
de 49.3 en 49.3 vous assurez le service
après-vente des caprices du président de
la République en l'espace d'un an vous
avez fait de notre pays une poudrière
bravo Madame la première ministre quel
anniversaire pendant les retraites elle
les débats sont survoltés votre méthode
assumée c'est l'obstruction
parlementaire et derrière ces gens Luc
Mélenchon qui tirent les ficelles
peut-être un peu trop pour certains
députés du groupe sur l'affaire catenas
qu'ils auraient aimé voir davantage
écartées après sa condamnation pour
violence conjugales sur le
fonctionnement du parti jugé trop
vertical et sur la stratégie
alors Mathilde panot vous devez composer
avec ces frondeurs vous la fidèle de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon votre victoire à vous
cette année c'est l'adoption de la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG je suis
très très émue à la fois de ce vote et
de se signaler historique
que l'Assemblée nationale sonore à
envoyer à toutes les femmes de notre
pays
[Applaudissements]
un texte rassembleur qui contraste avec
les propositions de loi clivantes du
groupe qui sont l'occasion pour vous de
faire du buzz comme celle sur la corrida
ou la réintégration des soignants non
vaccinés alors on a une question pour
vous Mathilde de panneaux vous relayez
la colère de l'Assemblée mais n'est-ce
pas au détriment de l'adoption de vos
propositions de loi
réponse
parce que ce n'est pas pour faire du
buzz et je voudrais insister là-dessus
lorsque on se bat pour l'abolition de la
corrida ce qui aimerait Caron apportait
brillamment pour notre groupe c'est
parce que nous pensons qu'il est urgent
d'abolir la corrida notamment pour des
raisons de bien-être animal dans ce pays
et que par ailleurs 87% des Français
sont favorables à ce que enfin on
abolissent la corrida quand nous parlons
de la réintégration des soignants qui
ont été suspendus parce que non vaccinés
nous pensons notamment à la situation en
outre-mer et aux Antilles spécifiquement
ou en Guyane ou le système de soins
s'effondre parce que beaucoup de gens
notamment parce qu'ils ont vécu le
scandale du chlore bacon ne voulait pas
se faire vacciner vous avez quand même
l'art de les fabriquer ces propositions
de loi vous êtes le groupe politique
dont les propositions là sont les plus
médiatiques à chaque fois que vous en
proposez une et c'est un talent elles
sont reprises partout parce qu'elles ont
là de frapper les esprits la
conflictualité c'est un principe
d'action dans les missiles c'est une
stratégie que vous assumez pleinement
vous avez vu qu'on n'a pas mis dans le
sujet la séquence retraite parce qu'elle
reste en mémoire des Français vous
n'avez pas le sentiment au fond que
cette stratégie n'a pas payé si elle a
payé regardez nous étions 17 nous sommes
75 mais là c'est après les retraites et
quand vous prenez oui mais on nous a dit
la même chose la dernière fois la
dernière fois sur la dernière bataille
retraite que nous avions gagné
on les ministres inventés que nous
avions fait 100.000 200000 amendements
des choses absolument incroyables et on
nous avait fait la même diabolisation
vous avez quand même participé à une
forme d'obstruction pour empêcher
l'article 7 le fameux report de l'âge
légal et vous l'assumez nous avions eu
raison parce que c'est ce qui a laissé
du temps au mouvement social de pouvoir
s'organiser c'est ce qui a laissé du
temps aussi pour un rapport populaire un
rapport de force populaire de ce faire
et notamment c'est grâce à ça que des
députés LR ont changé d'avis et que
aujourd'hui et c'est pourquoi ils nous
ont empêché de voter l'abrogation de la
retraite à 64 ans dans le cadre de la
Michelotte qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
prioritaire à l'Assemblée pour vouloir
l'abrogation de cette réforme François
Ruffin dit par exemple qu'il ne veut
plus hurler sur les bancs de l'Assemblée
ça ne sert à rien ça renforce le RN ce
sont ces mots il a complètement tort je
crois que nous avons dans le groupe
parlementaire et c'est une de nos
grosses forces nous avons des
complémentarités vous avez des gens qui
sont un facteur d'identification
magnifique je suis fier à un point que
vous ne pouvez même pas imaginer que
Rachel kéké soit député Rachel keké
première femme de ménage femme
victorieuse avec d'autres femmes de la
lutte de 22 mois de grève qui ont été
faits à l'hôtel Ibis Batignolles et
qu'elles ont gagné et qui derrière avec
des gens qui la regardent et qui se
disent moi aussi je déménage voilà
combat également de François Ruffin je
le souligne au passage parce qu'il a le
combat de François Ruffin également
exactement cette vidéo des femmes de
ménage notamment à l'assemblée qui donne
des liens d'identification pour les gens
lorsque vous disiez cet été l'été
dernier lorsque nous sommes rentrés à
l'Assemblée nationale pour cette
nouvelle mandature
que jamais autant de personnes n'avaient
regardé l'Assemblée nationale c'est vrai
je pense que c'est notamment grâce au
fait que avec notre groupe pas que mais
notamment c'est une évidence que vous
avez participé le peuple à la rendre
beaucoup plus regardée mais oui et pour
nous c'est important parce que avec la
politique et que justement le fait
d'avoir des complémentarités est une
chose qui permet d'avoir un message très
ample auprès des gens c'est l'heure du
bilan on voit bien que il y a des
réussites on voyait à l'IVG dans la
Constitution la nupesse il y a un désir
d'union chez Club de gauche comme on
appelle énorme ça marche à l'Assemblée
vous travaillez ensemble vous avez des
positions sur les textes quasiment les
mêmes pas tout le temps mais quasiment
les mêmes à chaque fois mais l'avenir
elle est tempérée cette alliance non
quand on voit que vous faites bande à
part aux européennes alors c'est pas
nous qui faisons barre d'appart puisque
c'est nous dans l'ensemble des
partenaires c'est puisque nous nous
militons depuis plusieurs mois pour que
les liée une liste unique européenne je
vais expliquer pourquoi j'espère que
nous pouvons convainc partenaires sur
cette question pourquoi parce que ce qui
est dit dans les sondages contrairement
à ce qu'on dit médiatiquement ce qui est
dit par les uns et les autres ce qui est
dit dans les sondages c'est que la
nupaisse unit serait la première force
aux européennes avant le rassemblement
national et évidemment mais il y a un
autre sondage qui montre que séparer les
forces de la nuit Pesse ont des réserves
de voies et sont à 10 points au dessus
une contradictoire parce que vous
comprenez non c'est pas contradictoire
vous comprenez bien que le soir des
élections européennes si le message
politique qui est envoyé à tout le pays
le signal politique c'est la nupesse est
la première force du pays où nous
pouvons d'ailleurs encore progresser par
rapport au sondage qu'il y a maintenant
puisque ce n'est pas maintenant c'est
dans un an
ce n'est pas du tout la même chose que
si c'est le rassemblement national qui
est la première c'est une évidence mais
l'impossible union aux européennes
aujourd'hui elle est largement imputée
c'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont à
écouter en coulisses les écologistes les
socialistes les propos de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sur l'Europe sur la Russie il
y a une forme voilà vous y
réconciliabilité là-dessus alors c'est
pas un peu de sa faute aussi non il y a
pile un an déjà c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui a impulsé les choses pour que ça
crée la nuit pêche je le remets quand
même je l'ai dit tout à l'heure et
personne ne trouve ça assez le contexte
alors que il est en train de justement
vouloir lui aussi une liste unique aux
européennes on dise maintenant qu'il
veuille détruire l'outil ce qui n'est
absolument pas le cas cette semaine ça
fait exactement un an que le premier
tour de l'élection législative a eu lieu
et nous avons gagné je le rappelle la
nuit Pesse le premier tour de l'élection
législative ensuite notamment parce que
beaucoup des candidats macronissent qui
avaient été défait ont préféré ne pas
faire aucun appel au vote voire à
appeler contre la nuit Pesse alors qu'il
y avait le RN en face nous sommes
retrouvés avec 89 députés RN ce qui est
là responsabilité historique des
macronistes je le dis pourquoi parce que
on ne va pas nous expliquer que nous
aurions été capables de gouverner il y a
pile un an ensemble sur un programme de
rupture qui est un programme de
gouvernement qui est toujours
d'actualité sur lequel nous nous
appuyons un accord électoral aussi
l'idée c'était quand même que voilà cet
accord a été décidé après la
présidentielle pas avant électorale ce
n'est pas qu'un
ministre comme vous exactement alors on
avance parce qu'il faut quand même qu'on
regarde
alors ensemble alors nous sommes
évidemment capables d'aller aux
élections européennes ensemble et vous
l'avez dit ça fonctionne très bien à
l'Assemblée on se voit toutes les
semaines tous les mois avec les 151
députés c'est dit donc nous pouvons
avancer ensemble les points noirs quand
même au sein de la France insoumise
c'est la gestion de l'affaire capden son
a parlé des réussites il y a aussi des
échecs est-ce que vous avez des regrets
vous êtes très féministe on l'a vu on
connaît vos combats sur la manière dont
les choses ont été géré il y a encore
beaucoup de militants au sein des filles
qui auraient préféré l'exclusion mais je
crois que c'est exigeant mais qu'il faut
tenir les deux fils je le dis parce que
je pense que au contraire nous avons
nous comme groupe parlementaire
affronter la situation et ne vont pas
mis en quelque sorte la tête dans le
sable en faisant semblant Jean-Luc
Mélenchon dit écoutez il dit un jour ou
l'autre Adrien katnas reviendra dans la
course c'est une maladresse de dire ça
vous le rediriez-vous ça je vais vous un
jour ou l'autre il reviendra dans la
cour et vous dire oui Adrien c'est
député il est député mais il reviendra
dans la course oui mais ce que ce que
écoutez dans je vais vous expliquer il y
a deux choses il y a évidemment la lutte
contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles qui a une lutte exigeante et
il y a aussi et il faut les tenir les
deux et c'est ce que je crois notre
groupe parlementaire a fait il y a aussi
la vision humaniste que nous avons de la
justice et je comprends que le mouvement
féministe n'en n'est pas là parce que je
comprends que l'impunité qui a valu sur
des gens auteur de violence pendant voir
pire pendant des dizaines et des
dizaines d'années amènent le mouvement
féministe à être très dur sur cette
question à dire qu'il faut être exigeant
mais Adrien katnens a été condamné il a
ensuite été sanctionné politiquement il
n'est plus coordinateur du mouvement il
a été suspendu du groupe parlementaire
pendant quatre mois il est très présent
quand même autour de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
manifestement vous avez lu comme où est
l'article du Monde publié aujourd'hui
mais écoutez alors il faut qu'on en
parle parce que il y a une question
c'est quand même ce qui s'appelle la
réinsertion comment est-ce qu'on fait
dans une société féministe débarrassée
du patriarcat comment est-ce qu'on fait
avec des gens qui ont été auteur de
violence ce que Adrien catenin ça
reconnu et dont il a subi les
conséquences qu'est-ce qu'on fait et je
le dis d'autant plus que c'est un moment
c'est exigeant cette question là et je
comprends que ça ouvre des colères et
des brèches énormes chez des gens mais
il y a un moment si on veut une société
féministe il faut penser aussi la
réinsertion des odeurs de violence c'est
dit c'est dit et on verra comment voilà
réagissent les Français mais c'est une
position claire et vous l'assumer les
méthodes il faut qu'on dise un mot pour
terminer cette interview des méthodes de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon verrouillage
généralisée dit certains en décembre les
historiques de les filles étaient
écartées la direction du mouvement
aujourd'hui le monde révèle à la suite
de Mediapart que certains militants sont
fichés que le poy le Parti ouvrier
indépendant
lambertise trotskiste historique de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a infiltré le parti
c'est alors c'est vrai ce qu'une
ambiance de purge
alors je vais dire très factuellement
sur des points pour aller rapidement la
première chose personne n'a été purgé de
la direction je vais dire le parti de
Clémentine Autain est invité au conseil
politique le parti de François Ruffin et
invité au conseil politique
Alexis Corbière n'avait jamais fait
partie de la coordination avant donc il
n'y a pas de purge c'est une chose qui
est inventée autour de ça la deuxième
chose sur le fichage de militants qui a
été révélé effectivement dans un journal
sur lequel vous avez un communiqué de la
France insoumise qui dénonce ses
méthodes et qui dont on ne sait pas d'où
elles viennent mais en tout cas qui ne
sont pas les méthodes de la France
insoumise et je veux le dire parce qu'il
y a une manière de décrédibiliser
l'alternative et la force politique que
nous sommes je vais vous dire je
comprends qu'on veuille taper et
continuer de taper sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais non mais je vous parle
pas forcément à vous mais je le dis je
comprends que on veuille taper sur un
homme qui a fait 22 100% aux élections
présidentielles qui a été trois fois
notre candidat et je vais vous dire si
nous sommes dans une situation avec 75
députés LFI si nous sommes dans une
situation avec 151 députés nupes ou
contrairement à tout le reste de
l'Europe notre famille politique et
écrasée et bien c'est grâce à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et si on peut réouvrir une
brèche d'espoir dans ce pays en Europe
c'est grâce à Jean-Luc Mélenchon et si
on peut représentant 2027 je ne sais pas
ça il décidera à aller je ne sais pas me
répondre on a plein de candidats
potentiels et ça c'est quand même très
bien et je vais vous le dis nous sommes
aujourd'hui à la fois sur la ligne de
rupture et de crédibilité parce que à
chaque projet de loi nous avons présenté
ce que nous nous ferions si nous étions
au gouvernement et nous aspirons
toujours à gouverner ce pays merci merci
ma petite panneaux vous restez avec moi
c'est l'heure d'accueillir la franchi
vous allez voir leur partie qui vont
vous faire réagir on les accueille tout
de suite
allez Vincent grand reporter qui va nous
parler de MBS dans un instant et puis le
philosophe Pierre-Henri tavoyot
installez-vous préparez on commence
comme chaque soir par Bourbon Express
nouvel épisode ce soir de notre série
spéciale un an de la nouvelle assemblée
avec homélette ce soir Marco pommier
bonsoir Marco bonsoir Myriam alors de
quoi nous parlez-vous ce soir et bah ce
soir à l'heure du bilan j'ai choisi de
vous parler d'une pratique que vous avez
contribué à vulgariser Mathilde panneaux
dans votre groupe c'est le name and
shame en bon français nommé et couvrir
de honte alors c'est une pratique
courante dans les pays anglo-saxons
objectifs dénoncer les auteurs de
mauvaises pratiques pour porter atteinte
à leur réputation pour changer elle les
comportements appliquées à la politique
ça consiste à demander des scrutins
publics dans l'hémicycle pour publier
ensuite la liste des députés qui ont
voté tel ou telle mesure sur les réseaux
sociaux l'insoumis François Ruffin était
l'un des premiers a lancé le concept
c'était en 2018 à l'époque on parlait
d'un texte pour améliorer le statut des
accompagnateurs des enfants handicapés
et la majorité avait adopté une motion
de rejet colère du député insoumis
j'espère que le pays ne vous pardonnera
pas nous vous demanderons un scrutin
public les noms des votants seront
publiques je les publierai sur ma page
facebook et je serai pas le seul il
circuleuront à travers la France et ce
vote ce vote j'en suis convaincu ce vote
vous collera la peau comme une infamie
et voilà Myriam comment François Ruffin
fait entrer dans l'hémicycle le pouvoir
de la honte alors cette année certains
insoumis n'ont pas renoncé à cette
pratique loin de là un exemple Louis
Boyard en février dernier il l'affichait
sur son compte Twitter les 194 députés
de la majorité qui avait voté contre le
repas à 1 euro pour tous les étudiants
indignation de certains membres de la
majorité regardez cette tweets il
dénonçait à des méthodes de voyous des
méthodes anti-démocratiques notre
République mérite mieux que l'appel à la
vindique populaire vous le voyez sur
cette image et le lendemain et bien le
député MoDem Erwan Balanant avait lui
aussi réagi dans l'hémicycle on l'écoute
un certain nombre de nos collègues sont
harcelés maintenant par les réseaux
sociaux alors vous pouvez penser que
c'est pas grave et effectivement c'est
pas si grave parce que parce que nous
sommes députés et que nous prenons des
risques et nous avons l'habitude mais
c'est députés c'est députés aussi
parfois des enfants et des enfants qui
sont aussi sur les réseaux sociaux et il
y a quelques députés qui ont vu leurs
enfants harcelés parce que leurs parents
avaient fait un vote et la voilà la
conséquence un pointée du doigt par
Erwan Balanant le harcèlement sur les
réseaux certains pointent même les
risques de violence envers les élus à
des critiques balayer par votre protégé
on écoute Louis Boyard
eux ils appellent ça le naimon shame moi
je Shy'm rien du tout je naïve c'est
tout je rencontre des votes je suis
chacun de mes votes je leur demande
d'assumer chacun de leur vote au moment
où on essaie de faire de la publicité
sur ce qui se passe ici et puis prennent
des mauvaises décisions qui vont énerver
les gens on vient ensuite nous voir en
disant non racontez pas qu'ils font
n'importe quoi sinon les gens vont
s'énerver mais qu'ils arrêtent de faire
n'importe quoi c'est pas nous qu'il faut
pointer du doigt voilà pas de regret
pour Louis Boyard rappelons quand même
Myriam que sur le fond le député
insoumise a commis aucune faute c'est un
procédé légal à l'Assemblée elle-même
publie sur son site le vote de chaque
député pour chaque scrutation pour
terminer il faut dire que les insoumis
ne sont pas les seuls à pratiquer le
gouvernement le fait exactement l'année
dernière le gouvernement a épinglé ses
entreprises qui ne respectaient pas
l'index égalité famome la liste avait
été publiée et dans l'actualité récente
et ben il y a aussi des menaces de Bruno
Le Maire le ministre de l'Économie
distribution effectivement qui a laissé
entendre qu'il pourrait publier d'ici la
fin du mois à la liste des industriels
de l'agroalimentaire qui n'auraient pas
qui aurait refusé de baisser les prix
face à l'inflation un mode de réaction
la pression peut être efficace mais elle
peut aussi
voilà avoir des dérives oui non mais ça
vous le reconnaissez l'harcèlement on ne
les harcèlement notamment sur les
proches des députés nous n'avons jamais
appelé à ça mais il faut quand même
remettre les choses à leur place si
c'est député va l'avoir des votes
secrets qu'ils aillent dans un conseil
d'administration les votes ne sont pas
secrets nous sommes des représentants du
peuple ils ont des comptes à rendre sur
ce qu'ils font ce qu'ils votent et
ensuite c'est à eux d'expliquer quelles
sont leurs votes donc non moi je trouve
ça normal dans une démocratie de faire
en sorte que chacun et chacune puisse
savoir qui a voté sur contre
l'augmentation du SMIC contre le repas à
un euro mais les réseaux sociaux
changent pas mal la donne dans tout bah
oui mais aussi à ce que beaucoup de gens
s'intéressent à la politique et je
trouve ça intéressant le bac philo est
passé carrément est envoyé et les
vacances s'approchent alors pour vous
c'est le bon moment pour revenir sur une
polémique assez récente sur les jours
fériés oui c'était une politique une
polémique qui a été lancée par le maire
de Grenoble au moment de la fin du
ramadan où il y avait beaucoup
d'absentéisme dans les écoles et des
agents et des élèves et donc le ministre
de l'Intérieur à cette occasion voulait
un peu pointer ces absences et donc
eripiol avait dit qu'il fallait un peu
remettre à plat les questions des jours
fériés avec deux propositions la
première je trouve d'ailleurs assez
intéressantes qui consistait à dire bon
lundi de Pentecôte correspond pas à
grand chose aujourd'hui remplacement par
une vraie date symbolique l'abolition de
l'esclavage ça c'était le projet de loi
en 2018 qui avait été proposé et puis il
y a une deuxième proposition alors qu'il
s'agit d'ouvrir les jours fériés ou la
diversité religieuse c'était là une
proposition de la Commission statique
avait dit je cite en 2003 la République
sonnerait en reconnaissant les jours les
plus sacrés des autres grandes religions
monothéistes présentes en France alors
là c'est quelque chose de plus compliqué
à mettre en place je suis pas persuadé
d'être tout à fait d'accord alors les
jours fériés religieux ça reste un point
de friction entre les cultes d'un côté
la République laïque de l'autre mais la
République a toujours le dernier mot en
effet quand on regarde l'histoire de
jours férié c'est très intéressant il y
a 11 jours fériés en France il y en a
six qui sont en lien avec la religion
sur ces 6 il y en a quatre qui ont une
histoire particulière faut rappeler que
sous l'Ancien Régime il y avait 50 jours
fériés la révolution abolie tout ça mais
c'est assez confus Napoléon arrive et
dans sa volonté de réconcilier l'Ancien
Régime et la Révolution qu'est-ce qu'il
fait il dit voilà il y a un principe
simple un jour férié par saison ça donne
quoi là tout simple Noël l'ascension et
l'Assomption le 15 août vous avez mis il
en reste deux dès lundi comme par hasard
coïncidence je ne crois pas en fait ce
ne sont pas des fêtes religieuses lundi
de Pâques et lundi de Pentecôte ne sont
pas de fêtes religieuses ce sont des
revendications des marchands du
Moyen-Âge parce qu'il fallait après les
fêtes justement se reposer et on peut
ajouter le dimanche le fameux dimanche
chômé que nous avons alors là aussi
l'histoire est intéressante la
révolution abolie ce dimanche chômé la
restauration leur Estor la République le
re supprime jusqu'à au 10 mars
1906 une tragédie à Corrège cour pardon
minière et qui était imputé à la fatigue
des ouvriers et donc c'est la CGT qui
demande à l'époque que l'on restaure un
jour férié nous sommes après la loi 1905
et ce sera le dimanche alors vous êtes
Napoléon les marchands la CGT séjour
chômés donc 10 religieux ne le sont pas
vous nous l'avez expliqué ou du moins
pas seulement oui pas seulement c'est
très important parce que ça donne bien
l'esprit de la laïcité la laïcité c'est
pas contre les religions le contrat de
laïcité c'est pas la religion c'est le
fondamentalisme le fondamentaliste c'est
quoi c'est la volonté de que tous les
jours soient religieux 24 heures sur 24
toutes les toute l'année et ce fond
d'année mentalisme chronophage allait
garder religions justement la laïcité
nous permet de nous en éloigner avec une
culture du compromis qui consiste à dire
grosso modo nous devons arbitrer entre
les mœurs nationales les spiritualité
individuelles l'utilité sociale la
symbolique collective il n'y a pas que
la religion dans la vie il peut y avoir
du religieux mais c'est ça le message de
la laïcité merci passionnant parti pris
la philosophie chohistorique et en phase
avec Piol tout est possible puis on est
à voyaux pour vous allez on enchaîne
pour vous laisser un peu de temps
Vincent vous vouliez revenir sur cette
visite à Paris dembs et oui Emmanuel
Macron remet donc le couvert un couvert
en argent massif et Or Noir pour
l'occasion non content d'avoir en
juillet dernier dérouler le tapis rouge
sous les pas de Mohamed Ben Salman notre
Jupiter élyséen des jeunes ras demain
avec le prince héritier saoudien il a
pour mieux flatter son note enclin à
débarquer sans préavis bousculer
l'agenda présidentielle c'est donc en
Seine-et-Marne et non à Pau François
Bayrou apprécie que Macron ira discourir
sur l'avion du futur il faut dire que le
fougueux timonier de la monarchie
wahabite vient un peu en voisin lors de
ses escapades hexagonales MBS séjours
dans son château de Louveciennes près de
Versailles un Sam suffit à 275 millions
d'euros conçu et bâti par le cousin de
Jamal cashoggi cette éditeuriste
dissident dont bensalman avait en
octobre 2018 ordonnée l'assassinat ét
suivi d'un équarrissage à la disqueuse
et ce dans l'enceinte du consulat
saoudien à Istanbul revient Mohamed tout
est pardonné alors c'est pas à vous que
voilà je vais dire mais je vais le faire
quand même comme les diplomates le
royaume saoudien acteur incontournable
aujourd'hui je connais la chanson et
quelques autres refrains dont cette
increvable rengaine furieusement Quai
d'Orsay si l'on ne devait parler qu'avec
les démocrates exemplaires on se
condamnerait au silence et à l'inaction
sus au droit de lomisme gloire au
pragmatisme au réalisme tous ces ismes
au large desquels périssent par noyade
conviction et principes une telle
doctrine repose sur un postulat bancal
la dialectique entre la morale et
l'efficacité serait un jeu à somme nulle
à cette zone là seul le cynisme est
performant tandis que la fidélité aux
valeurs affichées traceraient le chemin
le plus court vers l'impuissance pas si
vite ce qui vis-à-vis des despots de
toutes obédiences s'avèrent
contre-productifs c'est la complaisance
la souplesse des Chine confidence
recueillies ce matin même auprès d'un
vieux routier le métro monarchie comme
Vladimir Poutine MBS vrai bête politique
n’entend que les rapports de force et il
a compris un truc fort de son brut le
royaume peut tout acheter y compris ses
partenaires à vide de contrat du marché
d'armement au chantier BTP pharaonique
et est-ce que ça marche alors ce forcing
et oui la stratégie d'influence à la
Saoud inspiré au demeurant par le rival
catary fait ses preuves dans tous les
domaines y compris le sport et la
culture les pré-retraités du ballon rond
le Portugais Ronaldo le français Benzema
cautionne sans état d'âme mais apridor
une modernité de façade citons le Grand
Prix de Formule 1 de Jeddah le rallye
Dakar rapatrier dans les dunes mais
aussi la crème du Golfe mondial golf
sans eux du golf mondial que Riad
s'efforce d'attirer via un nouveau
circuit doté de prime délirante côté 7e
art et bien on le sait Maïwenn elle a vu
ça Jeanne Dubarry financé par une
fondation saoudienne ce n'est pas un
sujet d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il
m'intéressait car dit-elle en Arabie les
choses bougent une certitude l'éruptive
cinéastes Excel autant dans la fiction
que le film en costume à Paris MBS
plaidera en faveur de l'octroi à son
pays de l'Exposition Universelle 2030
nul doute que le prince mégalo s'effort
bien s'exposer pour ce qui est de
l'universalisme il y a du chemin à faire
à l'usurant milliers de ces sujets
décapités ou livrés au peloton
d'exécution depuis 2015 le message vaut
pour tous ceux qui œuvrent à sa
réhabilitation dis-moi qui tu courtises
je te dirai qui tu es qui tu es en trois
mots merci beaucoup toujours aussi bien
écrit Vincent et j'ai un tout petit mot
de réaction vous à faire sur la dernière
fois en juillet lorsqu'il était avec
lorsqu'il avait été reçu par Emmanuel
Macron on en refera de nouveau une autre
et merci pour les deux chroniques
passionnantes celles sur les jours
fériés parce que la fait partie de la
civilisation du temps libéré aussi de ce
que nous on porte et on avait porté avec
jean-huggratenant une proposition de loi
pour demander à ce que le 4 février soit
une journée fériée pour l'abolition de
l'esclavage et voilà et de rappeler
notamment sur la
un cas quand même qui fait
particulièrement honte à notre pays de
rappeler que il y a d'ailleurs
on verra ça merci merci les affranchis à
très vite Marco pommier et je vous
retrouve demain merci de nous avoir
suivi et merci à toute l'équipe de
sévères qui m'accompagnent tiens j'en
profite un tout petit peu à demain très
belle soirée
[Musique]